[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sciences publiques
vous le savez la promesse est dans le
titre de lait du sens à l'actualité et
se mettre au service du public vous
proposez des clés de compréhension des
crises que nous traversons et voici le
sommaire de ceux 20 février la zizanie
c'est une réforme qui sème la zizanie
dans presque toutes les familles
politiques de la nuque OLR en passant
par la majorité présidentielle le texte
sur la retraite à 64 ans sème la
division on analysera ces lignes de
fracture plus ou moins profondes qui
n'épargne pour l'instant que le
rassemblement national et puis c'était
il y a bientôt un an le 24 février 2022
j'ai pris la décision d'une opération
militaire
la Russie de Vladimir Poutine
envahissait l'Ukraine rares sont celles
et ceux qui imaginaient alors une guerre
aussi longue 12 mois plus tard c'est une
semaine spéciale Ukraine que l'on vous
propose dans la seconde partie de
l'émission premier chapitre tout à
l'heure consacré à la stratégie à la
personnalité et au verbe de volodime ski
mais d'abord avec la fin de l'examen du
texte sur les retraites à l'Assemblée
cette question que va-t-il se passer
maintenant en première réponse Jérôme
Rabier
l'examen de la réforme des retraites cet
achevée vendredi soir à l'Assemblée dans
une ambiance qui est un bon résumé des
deux semaines de débat chaotique et
inachevé les insoumis sont restés sourds
aux demandes des autres groupes de
retirer leurs amendements pour pouvoir
débattre du report de l'âge légal mesure
phare de cette réforme avant l'arrivée
du texte la semaine prochaine au Sénat
chaque camp va reprendre des forces mais
la stratégie des insoumis risque de
laisser des traces à gauche ça signe un
peu la fin d'un acte 1 de la nuit pêche
qui a fonctionné jusqu'à présent qui
était issu de l'élection présidentielle
et que maintenant nous passons nous
devons passer à un acte 2 dans tous les
cas au sein de l'assemblée je pense
qu'il va falloir voir en effet en
manière dont nous fonctionnons côté
syndical on prépare la suite et
notamment la prochaine journée de
mobilisation du 7 mars avec un mot
d'ordre mettre le pays à l'arrêt et du
côté de la CGT on envisage cette journée
comme un point de départ avant une
nouvelle phase on prépare le 7 mars mais
le 7 mars il y aura des deux nouvelles
assemblées générales qui diront on
continue demain et je pense d'ailleurs
que le lendemain ça ne vous a pas
échappé c'est le 8 mars j'en ai de
tourner internationale du droit des
femmes qui prend évidemment tous les ans
beaucoup de résonance mais encore plus
cette année avec cette réforme des
retraites ce projet de réforme qui va
impacter encore plus les femmes
l'occasion aussi pour les syndicats de
reprendre la main dans le débat avec un
avertissement lancé par la CFDT le 7
mars ce n'est pas la prolongation
du bordel qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée
nationale dans les rues le 7 mars c'est
la poursuite du mouvement syndical
orchestré dans une première
manifestation le 19 mars de 19 janvier
qui s'est poursuivi depuis avec
différentes dates maîtriser par les
organisations syndicales le risque pour
les syndicats et que l'unité se fissure
sur la suite à donner à cette journée du
7 mars une partie de la CGT poussant
pour des grèves reconductibles pour
l'instant rejeté par la CFD c'est donc
une nouvelle phase qui commence et on va
l'analyser ensemble avec mes invités
Christelle Craplet bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes directrice de BVA opinion
Mathieu Suker bonsoir et bienvenue
consultant et essayiste Benjamin Morel
bonsoir
constitutionnalisme être le conférence
en droit public à Paris 2 Panthéon Assas
et Frédéric Saez bonsoir journée
politique éditorialiste politique pour
sens publique vous serez là aujourd'hui
et demain bienvenue à vous bon si on se
propulse vers la seconde phase ou la
deuxième pourra peut-être qu'il y en
aura une troisième quatrième on verra
bien il faut aussi tirer le un peu le
bilan de la première c'est le cas est-ce
qu'il y a des gagnants des perdants ou
pas
premier constat il y a pas non plus un
acteur qui ressortirait particulièrement
gagnant tous les acteurs ont une
proportion de bonne image qui est
minoritaire chez les Français donc ça
c'est le premier point néanmoins quand
on compare il y a quand même une
catégorie un acteur qui ressort plus
gagnant ce sont les organisations
syndicales elles ont 44% de bonne image
elles ont donné quand même du crédit
elles ont donné le sentiment que ça se
passait bien qu'il y avait pas
débordement il y a un front uni leur
attitude est jugée constructive c'est
sans doute pour ça que les Français
voilà estiment que globalement ils ont
plutôt une bonne image de dans le cadre
de ce débat en revanche les parties
globalement ne sortent pas du tout
gagnant de cette séquence et notamment
la France insoumise qui est finalement
le parti qui a la plus mauvaise image et
notamment la plus forte proportion de
Français qui disent qu'ils en ont une
très mauvaise image donc on peut un peu
s'interroger sur le côté payant de cette
stratégie très offensive ça semble pas
pour le moment porter ses fruits dans
l'opinion Mathieu Suquet est-ce que le
de la relative on a bien compris
victoire ou bonne image des syndicats
elle elle se construit pas aussi en
contraste avec ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée c'est-à-dire qu'il y a il y
a ce cette union cette interdit
syndicale qui tient pour l'instant et
qui et qui organise des manifestations
qui elles aussi se passent dans
globalement de bonne commission il y a
assurément une sorte de chiant lié à
l'envers et personne ne l'avait vu venir
c'est-à-dire que au cours des dernières
années on avait vu l'affaiblissement des
organisations syndicales au point même
que des mouvements sociaux désormais en
fait s'organiser et parfois de façon
massive hors du cadre syndical
traditionnel voire même des mouvements
sociaux comme on l'a vu elle à la SNCF
en décembre dernier qui se
construisaient contre les organisations
syndicales en tout cas des organisations
syndicales qui ne les soutenaient pas du
tout voilà on voit qu'il y a
effectivement un retour des syndicats un
retour de la démocratie sociale et d'une
forme de démocratie sociale apaisée
parce que il y a une union inter
syndicale comme on en avait pas vu
depuis longtemps deux parce qu'il y a
effectivement des manifestations qui se
passent bien qui contrastent du coup
avec les manifestations qu'on a pu
connaître au cours des dernières et qui
dégénéré de façon systématique alors il
y a effectivement un protocole du
maintien de l'ordre qui a évolué du côté
de la préfecture de police ça doit jouer
bien sûr mais en tout cas on a des
organisations syndicales qui sont très
présentes dans le débat et qui organise
les mobilisations de la société civile
de façon apaisée ce qui dit que les
Français peuvent enfin re manifester je
voudrais dire de façon à peu près
tranquille alors qu'il y a quelques
années on était pas sûr de pouvoir aller
manifester sont à la fin se faire gazer
ou subir une charge et souvent le bilan
qu'on retenait d'une journée de
manifestation finalement c'était les
violences de
on a une démocratie sociale qui regagne
en maturité au moment où comme vous le
disiez vous-même par contraste on a une
démocratie parlementaire qui donne
d'elle-même un visage alors au-delà même
de de jugement de valeur qu'on peut
porter sur ce que certains ont qualifié
de cirque l'efficacité de tout cela le
fait que précisément en fait dans les
enquêtes d'opinion ça se traduise par un
moindre crédit pour les différents
partis politiques et je dirais même on y
reviendra en détail évidemment mais
allez-y quoi vous pouvez conclure
j'allais dire y compris chez les
sympathisants de la France insoumise ce
qui ah bon c'est quelque chose qu'on
observe en réalité depuis plusieurs mois
dans les enquêtes de la Fondation Jean
Jaurès notamment on avait pointé que
depuis l'élection présidentielle il y
avait dans le rapport à la posture
d'opposition des grands leaders de la
nupesse quelque chose de tout à fait
ambivalent la moitié y compris donc des
sympathisants de la France insoumise ne
se reconnaissent pas dans une posture
d'opposition frontale au Parlement la
moitié s'y reconnaît mais l'autre moitié
dit non un peu d'apaisement un peu
tranquillité du débat du compromis de
l'écouté du respect Benjamin Morel les
résultats des élections législatives on
en avait évidemment parlé ici même ça
devait en tout cas on l'espérait
permettre un rééquilibrage de nos
institutions donner à l'Assemblée
l'occasion de prouver qu'elle pouvait
co-construire autour des textes on peut
vraiment passer de parler d'une occasion
manquée là alors c'est en effet une
occasion manquée du point de vue
d'opinion en tout cas c'est à dire que
on peut discuter aujourd'hui du
rééquilibrage des institutions quoi
qu'on veuille quoi qu'on dise
aujourd'hui le sang du pouvoir a quand
même remigré un petit peu du côté du
Parlement et on a un gouvernement qui ne
peut pas exactement faire ce qu'il veut
et très clairement parler de la
stratégie de la fi bah cette stratégie
de la fi a plutôt profité infinie au
gouvernement qui ne s'est pas vu
parasiter par des amendements de briquet
de broc qui aurait conduit à des
majoritaires docks entre horizons le RN
la Nupe etc et aurait vu son texte des
figuré avec de grandes difficultés d'un
point de vue procédural pour ensuite
revenir dessus donc d'une certaine façon
pour le gouvernement ce qui s'est passé
n'est pas forcément une mauvaise
nouvelle même si on prend je parle sur
votre contrôle une enquête audoxalia
pour Le Figaro enfin de samedi qui
montrait que bah il était il paraissait
quand même comme étant le principal
responsable de ce qui s'était passé
devant l'opposition mais malgré ça d'un
point de vue purement procédural il en
sort plutôt vainqueur en revanche
l'image en effet le catastrophique
exactement parce que alors il faut
relativiser tout ça si vous prenez
l'obstruction tel qu'on la connaît elle
date pas de cette réforme elle a été
inventée dans sa forme moderne par la
droite sur la loi Savary les amendements
cocotiers etc c'était Jacques tout bon
c'est quelque chose entre guillemets qui
est ancien depuis au moins les années 80
ensuite c'est pas le record les 130 bien
sûr les 138000 amendements de Jean-Louis
Debré qui les monte sur la réforme de
def en 2006 c'est pas un record on était
à 20000 exactement la violence en
politique et au Parlement c'est pas non
plus nouveau je rappelle que le dernier
duel il était lié à un conflit entre
deux parlementaires c'est de faire et
rivière et en 1967 donc la violence au
Parlement elle a toujours existé quand
vous regardez un parlement du XIXe
siècle ou pire de la Révolution
française voyez ce que c'est la violence
en politique néanmoins là hein elle est
très visible parce qu'en effet il y a
une mise en visibilité par les caméras
ensuite elle est quand même très bas de
plafond sur certaines interventions
c'est peut-être un jugement de valeur
mais quand même je crois qu'il faut le
reconnaître et ensuite et je reviens ce
qui a été dit elle est qui plus est en
grande partie veine c'est à dire que le
point quand même sur cette stratégie
politique d'obstruction c'est qu'elle a
été malmenée mal construite et qu'elle
n'a menait pas à grand chose or en règle
générale une stratégie d'obstruction
elle mène toujours un débouché politique
ça pas été le cas alors dans cette
première phase il y a eu un grand absent
en tout cas si on compare à sa capacité
à prendre la parole régulièrement dans
d'autres phases politiques c'était
Emmanuel Macron évidemment demain il
sera à Rungis la carte postale on l'a en
la comprise c'est un message à la France
qui se lève tôt il est il est stable il
patie dans l'opinion de de cette
première séquence Emmanuel Macron et
puis peut-être en creux parce qu'on va
essayer de se poser cette question quel
peut être ça sera stratégie alors une
forme de rééquilibrage on va dire avec
un président qui a un petit peu plus en
retrait donc qui est moins frontale et
une première ministre qui va occuper la
première place donc pour l'instant c'est
plutôt elle on va dire élément du
gouvernement dans leur ensemble qui
pâtissent un peu plus de la séquence que
que lui donc voilà ça c'est pour le
premier point sur sur Emmanuel Macron
sur la suite toute sa stratégie ça va
être quand même de voir s'il arrive à
adopter sa réforme parce que c'est quand
même le point principal lui il joue
quand même son quinquennat et son image
de réformateur est-ce que ça stratégie
c'est c'est pas justement d'être le plus
silencieux possible pour pour le moins
pour une polarisé autour de lui alors ça
peut être une stratégie c'est d'ailleurs
un peu aussi la stratégie du
rassemblement national qui a été moins
présent et on les enquêtes c'est plutôt
payant pour le moment puisque comme je
disais tout à l'heure c'est le parti qui
apparaît finalement qui a la meilleure
image ou la moins mauvaise après ce sont
des stratégies un peu de court terme
parce que quand on réalise après enfin
quand on se projette un petit peu dans
le long terme faut voir quand même tout
ce qui va ressortir de cette séquence et
potentiellement chez les Français
forment quand même d'amertume de
rancoeur qui est pas forcément très
positif pour pour lui allez on se
projette dans dans les jours les
semaines qui qui viennent avec
évidemment cette journée du 7 mars qui
est qui est posée par l'intersyndical
depuis depuis plusieurs jours je propose
d'écouter le secrétaire général de la
CGT qui en appelle à l'imagination de
ces troupes
moi je compte sur vous sur votre
imagination pour que cette grève elle
s'amplifie partout avec les formes que
vous avez décidé avec des arrêts de
travail des débrayage partout dans les
entreprises et les services pour que on
pénalise évidemment ceux qui sont très
satisfaits de cette réforme c'est à dire
le patronat oui partout ayons faisons
preuve imagination pour qui les arrêts
de travail ceux qui veulent faire deux
heures tous les jours faites-le ceux qui
veulent partir en reconductible 24
heures on le fait partout partout il
faut que le travail s'arrête sous les
formes que vous aurez décidé avec vos
collègues et je vous l'assure
on est proche de la victoire alors
concluons l'essai et on va gagner merci
Mathieu souquière qui qui est le moteur
de cette de cette union syndicale de
cette inter syndicale là on a écouté
Philippe Martinez la nouveauté c'est
quand même plutôt Laurent Berger dans
cette posture là on peut dire ça alors
effectivement il y a cette nouveauté là
mais il y a de fait une forme de
convergence entre les deux ou en tout
cas même quand on entend monsieur
Martinez il est moins radical dans ses
propos qu'il ne l'a jamais été alors ça
veut pas dire encore une fois que les
modalités d'action qu'il préconisent ne
soit pas un peu différente de celle que
la CFDT promeux donc chacun a fait un
pas vers l'autre en quelque sorte ça
semble assez évident néanmoins la
posture d'opposition la posture de
confrontation contestataire de la CGT
elle est habituelle tout le monde y est
habitué ce qui est évidemment marque une
vraie différence c'est la posture de la
CFDT Laurent Berger est un homme modéré
il est à la tête d'une organisation
plutôt tempérée plutôt constructive
prête à accompagner un certain nombre de
réformes il était d'ailleurs tout à fait
en osmose avec les pouvoirs publics au
moment de la réforme de 2019 la fameuse
sous forme de la retraite à points et là
précisément il assombré dans une
opposition extrêmement vindicative
contre la réforme qui a pesé très fort
en fait dans l'opinion si l'opinion y
est très majoritairement hostile si elle
a retenu que la réforme n'était ni
urgente ni équitable ni efficace c'est
précisément parce que Laurent Berger a
mis toute sa crédibilité dans le débat
Frédéric et ce qui est intéressant aussi
dans ce qu'on vient d'entendre dans le
discours de Philippe Martinez c'est
qu'il y a une sorte de décentralisation
de la décision faites comme vous voulez
au niveau de vos entreprises c'est
presque par contraste qu'on avait dit
pour certaines réformes sociales ce sont
des envies des entreprises qui devaient
négocier à leur niveau et non plus au
niveau des branches là c'est aussi non
plus au niveau du syndicat qui dit voilà
une action unitaire qui va se dérouler
comme tel mais c'est vous en fonction du
rapport de force locale de vos
personnalités de votre historique qui
allait décider qu'est-ce que ça montre
ça ça montre un esprit d'ouverture ou
une certaine faiblesse à faute de
pouvoir imposer sa propre doctrine ses
propres méthodes sur le terrain sans
doute la préoccupation de ne pas se
couper effectivement d'une partie de
l'op parce que tout l'enjeu est
effectivement là faire en sorte que la
sympathie qui aujourd'hui en fait se
manifeste derrière le mouvement ne
décroche pas national on l'a déjà dit
ici mais c'est important de le rappeler
il y a des manifestations dans beaucoup
de la petite ville moyenne des
sous-préfecture celle où les services
publics parfois reculés etc et très et
très présente effectivement dans le
mouvement et dans le même temps un
Philippe Martinez qui faisait lui-même
la leçon alors Laurent Berger faisait la
leçon à l'ensemble des parlementaires en
dénonçant le gâchis le gâchis
parlementaire Philippe Martinez lui-même
faisant la leçon à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
sur la responsabilité à avoir en tant
qu'acteur du mouvement alors on va se
projeter maintenant vers le Sénat et je
propose à Quentin Calmet qui doit être
juste derrière dans les coulisses
bonsoir Quentin bienvenue à vous la
réforme des retraites qui qui arrivent
la semaine prochaine c'est ça au Sénat
c'est ça en ce moment au Sénat on est en
train effectivement de terminer d'écrire
des amendements par exemple pour les
sénateurs pour les déposer ou encore de
préparer les stratégies de chaque groupe
regardez le calendrier de l'examen à la
chambre haute le texte arrive d'abord en
commission des affaires sociales où il
sera examiné ce sera le 28 février cela
va donner déjà une idée de la stratégie
de chaque groupe politique attention
c'est débats en commission ne sont pas
publiques au Sénat contrairement à
l'Assemblée nationale on rentre vraiment
dans le vif des débats à partir du 2
mars avec la discussion générale puis
l'examen d'émotions déposé par la gauche
que ce soit une notion référendaire ou
une notion de rejet ensuite l'examen des
articles et amendements va se poursuivre
du 3 au 12 mars 11 12 mars qui est le
dernier jour prévu au calendrier avec
une autre particularité au Sénat par
rapport à l'Assemblée nationale la
séance va être ouvert tous les week-ends
au total 11 jours Thomas prévus jusqu'au
12 mars pour examiner la réforme des
retraites c'était 9 à l'Assemblée
nationale et alors que sait-on de la
façon dont ça va se dérouler ici au
Sénat alors déjà il n'y a pas de
sénateur de la France insoumise ou du
rassemblement national au Sénat on va
forcément voir une différence de ton
d'autant que la tradition au Sénat de
débattre sereinement même s'il y a
parfois des passes d'armes ici à la
Chambre haute elles sont quand même
moins fréquentes qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale d'ailleurs les opposants à la
réforme au Sénat ils le disent eux même
hors de question de rejouer les débats
des députés ils veulent s'opposer à la
réforme sur le fond alors on va analyser
les stratégies la stratégie de la gauche
d'abord oui allons-y même sans la LFI le
PS les Verts et les communistes
entendent bien utiliser toutes les armes
parlementaires ont-ils disposent on
parle alors d'une forme de guérilla
parlementaire d'ailleurs ces groupes
politiques révisent en ce moment le
règlement du Sénat pour utiliser un
maximum d'outils mis à leur disposition
on l'a dit ils vont donc déposer des
motions pour s'opposer au texte dès le
début de son examen écoutez un sonateur
socialiste Rémy Féro c'était ce matin
sur notre antenne aura d'émotion de
procédure porter par la gauche il y aura
beaucoup d'amendements notre volonté à
la fois de discuter l'article 7 nous
opposer à cette réforme et de tout faire
dans le respect des règles et dans le
respect des personnes aussi de tout
faire pour que le Sénat n'adopte pas
cette réforme nous le ferons donc il y
aura beaucoup d'amendements et nous
serons très présents parce que
parallèlement au mouvement social c'est
évidemment ce débat au Sénat évidemment
extrêmement important voilà vous
l'entendez un Thomas qui parle bien et
bien d'examiner l'article 7 à celui sur
le report de l'âge des départs à la
retraite en revanche la gauche qui va
tout faire pour que l'examen de la
réforme de la réforme n'aille pas au
bout et qu'il n'y ait pas de vote sur
l'ensemble du texte allez que la
stratégie de la droite maintenant et
bien à l'inverse de la gauche la droite
vous voyez si c'est un peu l'ancien
monde à gauche droite c'est la droite va
tout faire pour adopter sa version de la
réforme pour rappel depuis 2018 les
sénateurs LR ont fait ajouter le
décalage de l'âge de départ à 64 ans
tous les ans dans le budget de la Sécu
mais attention dans les détails il
pourrait y avoir aussi des façons de
remodeler le texte pour les LR ils sont
sceptiques par exemple sur l'index au
Seigneur dans les entreprises mais aussi
sur d'autres volets du texte écoutez le
LR René Paul savar
préoccupation nous à travers ce texte
qui est quand même limité dans son
analyse c'est un texte budgétaire c'est
quand même de prendre en compte
davantage les problèmes familiaux qui
sont pas suffisamment prises en compte
et c'est tout à fait essentiel dans le
cadre de l'équilibre d'un système
d'appareil partition et faire des
propositions également de la prise en
compte de l'usure professionnelle on
peut améliorer les dispositifs qui ne
sont proposés donc c'est ce niveau là
que nous travaillons voilà ça promet 11
jours intense alors sur le thème de
publics notamment ah oui on va avoir
beaucoup d'éditions spéciales évidemment
week-end compris merci Quentin Benjamin
Morel 11 jours moi j'ai retenu ça 11
jours pour examiner l'ensemble du texte
même si c'est un tout petit peu plus
qu'à l'Assemblée ça reste court ça reste
court après ça dépend comment est-ce que
vous siégé donc elles conditions etc et
on peut monter jusqu'à 15 donc de toute
façon enfin on joue en séance mais de
toute façon on reste sur un texte qui
début de son ampleur peut malgré tout
être examiné sans trop de difficultés
dans le timing proposé après la question
c'est qu'est-ce que vous entendez par
examiner et là on rejoint encore la
question de l'obstruction alors si vous
rencontrez la plupart des sénateurs et
vous diront que l'obstruction au Sénat
ça n'existe pas bien sûr que si ça
existe et la plupart des réformes du
règlement de les années 80 à l'Assemblée
commence au Sénat ont eu un objectif
juguler justement ce phénomène
d'obstruction après cette obstruction
elle est en effet en règle générale un
peu moins massive un peu moins
caricatural et il y a une volonté des
groupes de gauche et bien d'avoir une
logique d'obstruction qui va être
probablement un peu différente grosso
modo vous pouvez avoir un texte qui est
fondamentalement modifié par rapport à
ce qu'on entend le gouvernement si ce
texte est fondamentalement modifié parce
que des majorités Haddock se sont
construites sur tel ou tel amendement
jusqu'à quand le gouvernement peut
arriver à tenir son texte jusqu'à quand
il peut être considéré comme n’étant pas
embêté par le texte même qu'il a
souhaité mettre en place sachant que
infini la commission mixte paritaire
après et bien sera une commission juste
paritaire à dominante LR beaucoup plus
que ensemble et donc ce faisant il y a
une risque il y a un risque de perte de
contrôle si vous rajoutez en plus le
fait que et bien vous n'arrivez pas
jusqu'à la fin de l'article 7 ou en tout
cas que vous n'avez pas vous n'arrivez
pas jusqu'à la fin du projet de loi et
bien vous fragilisez et la légitimité
potentiellement la constitutionnalité de
votre texte donc tout ça mis Boutin de
bout en bout en réalité ben vous mettez
le gouvernement dans une situation qui
est une situation compliquée ça implique
de faire de l'obstruction intelligente
et c'est probablement à ça qu'on va
assister et donc si on vous entend bien
Benjamin Morel il y a presque plus de
risques pour le gouvernement lors du
passage au Sénat que lors du passage à
l'Assemblée nationale par rapport à la
stratégie qui était celle de la fi
probablement c'est à dire qu'il y avait
plusieurs stratégies possibles à
l'Assemblée nationale ce que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure si jamais vous aviez eu
sur cet examen des amendements adoptés
avec quelques voix du MoDem de 3
quelques voix d'horizon quelques voies
du RN etc et un texte profondément
modifié il finit ça aurait été très très
compliqué pour le gouvernement de
revenir dessus d'abord parce que au
Sénat il peut pas introduire de mesures
nouvelles et que qui plus est bien un
amendement au gouvernemental au Sénat
pour revenir à une mesure antérieure
c'était compliqué donc si jamais il y
avait eu un autre jeu d'obstruction
probablement que le gouvernement aurait
été beaucoup plus embêté c'est
probablement le jeu qui va être mené au
Sénat oui mais c'est pour ça que cette
réforme elle ressemble
à si méprendre à ce qui était d'abord ce
qui était voté quand elle rappelait ici
au Sénat depuis plusieurs années et puis
ce qui était quand même Mathieu Suker
dans le programme de la candidate LR à
la présidentielle faut faut pas
l'oublier si on reprend un peu la
stratégie des oppositions moi ce que je
retiens c'est quand même l'idée de
jamais aller au bout du texte de ne pas
donner une victoire quelle qu'elle soit
au gouvernement et la majorité
présidentielle ce que vous dites ça
Mathieu oui alors peut-être en tout état
de cause la cacophonie à laquelle on a
assisté à l'assemblée nationale il n'y a
pas de raison qu'on la retrouve au Sénat
on devrait avoir une séquence
parlementaire radicalement différente la
cacophonie elle tenait en particulier au
fait que il y avait une forme de
confusion au le discours au
gouvernemental on l'a compris la
pédagogie comme on dit avec beaucoup de
guillemets la pédagogie a été assez
ratée il y avait par ailleurs des
divisions propres à la nupense qui ont
émergé très rapidement mais qui se sont
confirmés jusqu'à la fin et quand on
entend Sandrine Rousseau aujourd'hui qui
n'est pas la plus modérée en fait au
sein de la nupesse faire elle-même une
forme de leçon en fait de tempérance à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon on va précisément
cette division de la nupes elle
n'existera pas au Sénat parce que la
nupesse n'existe pas au Sénat elle est
finie et par présentée or les postures
d'opposition et d'invectives c'était
pour le coup le propre de LFI je ne
cible pas en disant cela mais le seul
vrai groupe qui se soit mobilisé pour
mettre un peu de désordre dans les
débats parlementaires c'était les filles
pour l'avoir d'ailleurs théorisé en été
l'idée c'est que la colère populaire
soit représentée soit incarnée y compris
au Parlement considérant que en
l'incarnant d'une certaine façon on la
canalise on la neutralise certains
pensent qu'au contraire on l'attise mais
donc ça pour le coup ça n'existera pas
au Sénat et dernière dimension celle que
vous évoquiez la division de la droite
qui me paraissait chauffer farfelu
effectivement à l'Assemblée nationale
avec une vraie difficulté pour
eriksiotti et Olivier marlex à tenir
leurs troupes finalement l'exclusion
d'Aurélien Pradier au Sénat a priori on
devrait être sur quelque chose de
beaucoup tranquille parce que la ligne
sénatoriale c'était effectivement la
ligne le canal historique de LR sur la
question des retraites alors on va
démarrer sur autour de ce terme de
zizanie moi c'est ce qui me frappe quand
même comment ce texte quand même sème le
trouble la dynamie au sein des familles
poétiques en tout cas de une majorité de
famille politique on va faire un focus
maintenant avec vous Frédéric sur la
stratégie et les filles on en a déjà un
peu parlé mais c'est intéressant de voir
qu'elle fait un peu l'unanimité contre
elle d'ailleurs il y a deux dimensions
il y a la tactique et puis il y a la
forme la tactique c'est effectivement de
ne pas arriver surtout pas à cet article
7 le fameux qui repousse l'âge légal à
64 ans on en a beaucoup parlé par cette
nuée d'amendements que vous évoquiez
c'est l'obstruction ça c'était horrible
et puis la forme aussi vous en parliez
la conflictualité Jean-Luc Mélenchon en
a beaucoup parlé lui-même effectivement
l'outrance il faut y aller à fond il
faut pas hésiter à être tranchant
parfois insultant on a quand même
entendu un ministre se faire traiter
d'assassins par un député LFI au cours
de cette session ça aussi c'est
terrorisé par les insoumis par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon d'ailleurs en meeting il l'a
dit lui-même à Montpellier Jean-Luc
Mélenchon moi je ne m'excuse jamais y
compris quand il y a beaucoup de battage
médiatique comme ça
de l'insulte en question exactement et
donc voilà les deux les deux bouts de
cette stratégie à la fois les
amendements et à la fois la forme très
tranchante c'était horrible c'est
assumer effectivement en dehors de la
France insoumise c'est difficile de
trouver des soutiens à cette stratégie
même parmi les pontes de cette
opposition à la réforme des retraites
dans le champ syndical par exemple le
chef de fil de la CGT Philippe Martinez
alors lui certes il reproche au
gouvernement d'avoir utilisé d'après lui
un artifice pour limiter la durée
d'examen du texte mais ces reproches
vont aussi durement vers les outrances
des insoumis qui d'après lui font
diversion et détournent du fond des
discussions
l'Assemblée nationale notamment quand il
s'agit d'une loi et d'un mouvement
social doit être au service de ce
mouvement social or au travers de
nombreux incidents on va dire ça comme
ça on a plus évoqué ces incidents que le
fond du problème et ce qui est en débat
dans la rue et Philippe Martinez va même
plus loin il a dit à cause de ses
incidents Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'est pas
l'Allier du mouvement social il l'a dit
il y a quelques heures Philippe Martinez
rejoint d'ailleurs sur cette question
par par Laurent Berger le secrétaire
général de la CFDT
je crois qu'il est Martinez a raison sur
ce point très clairement je crois même
je vais vous dire que il faut qu'on se
dise très clairement les choses le 7
mars ce n'est pas la prolongation du
bordel qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée
nationale dans les rues le 7 mars c'est
la poursuite du mouvement syndical
orchestré dans une première
manifestation le 19 mars 19 janvier qui
s'est poursuivi depuis avec différentes
dates maîtriser par les organisations
syndicales ce ne sera pas la suite du
bordel de l'Assemblée nationale en
disant ça Laurent Berger dit j'ai peur
en fait que ce spectacle désolant
finalement décourage une partie des
personnes qui sont opposées à la réforme
des retraites de se joindre au cortège
presque par dégoût par par répulsion
donc ça c'est quoi ces syndical côté
politique et côté politique pareil vous
regardez la nups en dehors des insoumis
et encore ils sont divisés au sein de
leur groupe mais vous avez tout de même
des personnalités communistes comme
André Chassagne qui a été c'est le
président du groupe communiste à
l'Assemblée nationale qui a été très
choquée parce qu'il a entendu dans
l'hémicycle au nom des députés du groupe
la gauche et républicaine
je tiens à dire à quel point nous sommes
choqués par les propos qui ont été tenus
et j'ajouterai
nous
serons porter une parole sans concession
mais jamais je dis bien jamais nos
débats nos arguments ne doivent dériver
avec des insultes qui sont portés contre
des membres de cette assemblée et contre
des membres du gouvernement
la majorité les communistes qui avaient
décidé comme les socialistes comme les
écologistes de retirer leurs amendements
pour en arriver plus vite à ce fameux
article 7 mais elle est fille bien sûr
si est opposée s'est mis en travers du
chemin même Sandrine Rousseau l'a
entendu chez les verres critiques
maintenant cette décision et dit même
qu'il va falloir revoir le
fonctionnement de cette alliance de
gauche de la un acte de commande
exactement alors on voit parmi les
opposants à la réforme des retraites la
ligne LSI fait l'unanimité mais contre
elle et tous les personnes qu'on a
entendu là à l'instant c'est le paradoxe
d'ailleurs sont traités à la France
insoumise de diviseurs voilà c'est
division contre division Christelle
Crapelet on l'a évoqué mais je voudrais
bien qu'on rentre dans le détail de de
ce que cette stratégie provoque chez les
sympathisants et les filles parce que on
pourrait se dire bon bah très bien il
parle d'abord à leur cœur battant leur
cœur électoral c'est pas si simple non
alors ceci dit
dans les psifiquement sur le projet de
réforme ils font quand même un peu corps
derrière derrière la stratégie on a je
crois plus de 80 % des sympathisants à
les filles qui ont une bonne image donc
j'ai envie de dire que la stratégie
peut-être parle quand même voilà au cœur
de cible on va dire en revanche pour
élargir ce cœur de cible convaincre des
personnes et notamment des gens qui font
partie de la nupette qui sont
sympathisants ELV sympathisants PS eux
sont beaucoup plus circonspects
effectivement ils ont beaucoup moins une
bonne image ils sont plus partagés donc
ça recréer effectivement un peu de
division au sein même des sympathisants
faisant écho à la division qu'on a pu
observer chez les députés de chacune des
composantes de la nupesse alors c'est
intéressant parce que il y a donc les
débats au Sénat qui sont en train de se
préparer tribune publiée chez nos
confrères du monde aujourd'hui une
cinquantaine de
trentaine pardon d'élus socialistes qui
consignent une tribune qui condamne le
projet de réforme des retraites du
gouvernement évidemment qui jugent
injuste et efficace mais ce qui est
aussi intéressant il estime irréalistes
les 60 ans et les 40 annuités de
cotisations pour tous donc là on a à
Patrick cannaire le président qui signe
Hidalgo on a une Carole d'Elga la
présidente de la région
Occitanie Benjamin Morel
cette partie de la nuque puisque elle
est finie par présentée ou au Sénat
cette partie de la nuple enfin
l'occasion de résister un petit peu
est-ce qu'on peut dire ça comme ça ah
oui c'est une partie on va dire très en
dissonance de la Nupe parce que là vous
citez évidemment des noms partis
socialiste
de le dire donc en effet ça va marquer
des tensions au sein même du groupe
socialiste ici et au sein même du Parti
socialiste qui ici et Ben est la
principale composante de la nuque donc
ça peut avoir un jeu qui va être un jeu
singulièrement différent après la
question c'est est-ce que ça peut être
mieux reçu par la base de gauche et ça
c'est pas tout à fait évident en réalité
cette stratégie d'obstruction de la fi
on peut la juger en grande partie
problématique mais il faut voir à quoi
ça sert l'obstruction l'abstruction ça
sert à deux choses historiquement soit
évoqué le processus donc quel processus
vous ne pouvez pas aujourd'hui parce que
avec le 47 tiens il n'y a pas de
possibilité de bloquer ou bien à diviser
la majorité et lorsque vous divisez la
majorité soit vous la divisez face à un
mur qui est un mur et bien de qui va
être lié au France syndicales etc là le
temps était trop court pour la diviser
soit vous la divisez parce que et bien
vous la divisez sur des sujets qui
peuvent potentiellement tirer à
l'intérieur c'est ce qui va tenter
d'être fait au Sénat l'autre option et
c'est un peu la stratégie de la fi qui
autre également il y a une volonté de
des stabiliser en des légitimement la
réforme mais c'était de dire en
construisant un parlement cocotte-minute
et bien ce Parlement cocotte-minute va
être tellement insupportable qu'on va
avoir un effet désengagement et que
potentiellement à un moment ça peut
craquer c'est ce qui a pas marché à
l'Assemblée c'est ce qui marchera
évidemment pas au Sénat et ce sera pas
une bataille menée donc avoir justement
si au-delà des divisions au sein de la
nuque il peut y avoir des modulus
Vivendi pour malgré tout et bien
construire des majorités à doc pour
faire avancer le texte avec avec en
effet un groupe LR sur une ligne
Retailleau ça a quand même être très
compliqué Matthieu souker je parle de de
dissension la Nupe elle a tenu dans
cette dans cette acte on a cité son
émotion on l'a entendu dans le sujet
tout à l'heure qui dit bah maintenant
faut inventer autre chose ça peut être
quoi alors paradoxalement elle a mieux
tenu que LR alors que la nuque
précisément c'est quand même un alliage
de partie différent avec d'ailleurs au
départ des bases programmatiques
différentes voilà et l'air a eu plus de
mal à constituer l'unité jusqu'au bout
alors que pourtant normalement ces
propositions sont assez simples je
dirais que le l'effet délétère du débat
à l'Assemblée tient au fait que il y a
eu obstruction c'est-à-dire qu'un
certain nombre de parties par posture
ont empêché le débat de se nouer le fait
qu'il y a eu une forme de confusion
entretenue par la communication
maladroite du gouvernement et par
ailleurs le fait que le débat a été
escamoté aussi parce que peu
d'opposition sont venus avec des
contre-propositions crédibles permettant
d'alimenter un vrai débat de fond sur
notre modèle social la place du travail
etc et donc une partie de la de
l'opinion tient précisément en fait que
on n'a pas eu projet contre projet
débats programme contre programme un
vrai débat de fond certains
parlementaires quand même disent que au
contraire en commission en particulier
mais y compris dans l'hémicycle ils ont
un certain moment eu de vrais débat de
fonds extrêmement approfondie poussée
intéressant etc ce que malheureusement
l'opinion n'a pas du tout perçu mais du
coup une remarque par rapport à la
tribune que vous évoquiez je suis frappé
de voir que là où le débat a pu être
posé même s'il a été peu posé il a été
posé en des termes qui sont a été
comparables à ceux qu'on avait utilisé
en 2010 en 2003 et je dirais même en
1991 que la que la gauche est proposée
en fait d'en revenir à la retraite à 60
ans de façon uniforme qu'elle se soit
entendue là dessus est un peu étonnant
parce que encore une fois je ne conteste
pas le fait que il faille faire de la
justice sociale dans une réforme et que
la gauche est fondée à porter cela mais
en revenir à la retraite à 60 ans alors
même que le même âge légal aujourd'hui
qu'il soit à 62 à 64 ou à 5 ans les
critiquer au motif que entre les riches
et les pauvres entre les cadres et les
ouvriers l'espérance de vie est
tellement différente que un système avec
le même âge légal en réalité et financé
par des pauvres pour permettre aux
riches de vivre plus longtemps à la
retraite le problème est exactement le
même avec la retraite à 60 ans et donc
je suis frappé que la gauche elle-même
en fait n'est pas davantage travaillé
son sujet que de proposer le retour à ce
qui était la situation en 1981 vous vous
l'avez évoqué le chez les effectivement
cette zizanie chez LR le président Alexi
a donc demi Aurélien Pradier ses
fonctions de numéro 2 du parti et le
député du Lot a réagi par communiquer en
disant ceci cette réforme des retraites
reste injustée mal préparée face au
gouvernement les Français attendent des
républicains de la force de la justice
et du respect pas des négociations
derrière cuisine politique Christelle
rappelait Aurélien parisien il reste
quand même minoritaire au sein de l'ère
donc c'est relativement facile pour
erikiotine montrer ses muscles dans un
contexte comme celui-là est-ce qu'on
peut dire ça oui et d'autant que
regarder en termes d'opinion ce que
pensent les sympathisants LR alors
certes ils approuvent pas dans les mêmes
proportions que les sympathisants
Renaissance mais globalement ils sont
majoritairement pour la réforme donc
effectivement il a plutôt intérêt à
montrer qu'il y a une forme d'unité
derrière en appuyant sur un sujet qui
fait globalement plutôt consensus chez
ses sympathisants Benjamin si on fait le
bilan quand même de cette quinzaine tout
le monde était un peu à contre-emploi
c'est assez c'est non mais vraiment quoi
alors nous ça nous donne beaucoup de
grains moule c'est passionnant pour des
observateurs comme nous mais on s'y
attendait pas forcément à ce contre
emploi crise presque généralisé on s'y
attendait pas forcément mais si vous
prenez le groupe LR la question c'est
une question de positionnement si vous
voulez incarner l'opposition demain sur
une réforme emblématique du gouvernement
quelle est la bonne stratégie la
stratégie de je suis ma colonne
vertébrale parce que je suis ça une
question qui est une question de
finances publiques mais qui en réalité
aujourd'hui intéresse je parle sous
votre contrôle beaucoup moins les
Français et qui apparaît
fondamentalement impopulaire mais en
même temps ça a été mon ADN pendant des
années où est-ce que je me pose au
gouvernement parce que sous la Cinquième
République si vous voulez incarner
l'alternance il faut l'alternative et
donc il faut apparaître comme étant
l'exact négatif du gouvernement et
surtout pas en être la roue de secours
et là on a en effet un jeu qui est un
jeu je dirais logique de positionnement
pour une opposition qui est extrêmement
compliqué à mener ensuite vous avez une
caractéristique du groupe Air c'est un
groupe de survivants et c'est un groupe
fondamentalement des structuré avant
même cette réforme c'est eux qui sont le
moins présent en séance et qui votent le
plus en ordre dispersé et donc parler de
l'Assemblée nationale à l'Assemblée
nationale le problématique au Sénat est
pas du tout la même bien là d'ailleurs
on pourrait discuter des rapports de
force du coup entre les deux groupes et
entre leurs deux chefs mais leur chef
officieux à l'Assemblée nationale leur
chef officiel au Sénat mais pour le
groupe LR à l'Assemblée nationale si je
m'appelle Éric Ciotti et que je décide
de dîner avec le gouvernement et que je
tiens pas mes parlementaires dans quelle
mesure j'ai un poids dans quelle mesure
mon groupe pèse réellement dans quelle
mesure je suis ou pas quelque chose
c'est pas si évident et quand vous voyez
ce qui s'est passé pendant 20 jours à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui il est
pas évident que le groupe LR soit
justement ce groupe charnière dont on a
tellement parlé donc cette sanction
Pradier par nos interrompre vous y
verrez plus un constat de faiblesse
exactement c'est plus un contrat un
constat de faiblesse il l'aurait fait au
tout début de la Réforme et Aurélien
Pradier serait resté soit isolé soit
rentré dans le rang c'était une position
de force là il le fait à la fin le
faisant à la fin il tente de montrer
qu'il a une forme d'autorité sur son
groupe mais cette autorité elle est
assez faible le fait qu'Aurélien Pradier
dise finalement je m'en moque un petit
peu je vise l'avenir et de toute façon
et bien rien n'est joué au sein de ce
parti politique montre que là aussi on a
un leadership piotique qui aujourd'hui
est fondamentalement contesté autant
qu'il va être remis en comparaison avec
un autre leadership celui-ci Bruno
retaillod et on voit même que au sein de
la majorité présidentielle c'est c'est
pas évidemment monolithique distension
la preuve avec ce communiqué de député
horizon le parti de l'ancien pré-uni
Édouard Philippe après avoir échangé
avec les habitants de nos
circonscriptions et écouter les Français
nous avons déposé un abonnement visant à
ce qu'aucune personne éligible au
dispositif carrière longue mais à cotisé
plus de 43 ans pour bénéficier d'une en
fait à taux plein Matthieu souker la
major dans ce dossier et puis là on
revient à on revient à quand le texte
reviendra l'assemblée la majorité
présidentielle elle a pas fini de se
compter ça va être au député près quoi
l'histoire je crois que de plus en plus
de commentateurs quand même considère
que Emmanuel Macron c'est plus ou moins
mis dans une forme d'impasse politique
c'est-à-dire que effectivement il est
obligé d'aller au bout de sa réforme
sinon il a perdu définitivement son
image de réformateur et sa capacité à
agir pendant les quatre années qui lui
restent mais en passant sa réforme
malgré tout en force on voit bien que il
risque de se couper encore davantage de
l'opinion l'opinion ne lui est pas
acquise depuis sa réélection et au
contraire l'opinion lui un temps de
constamment un procès depuis 5 ans en
déconnexion en arrogance en éloignement
avec les les préoccupations de proximité
des Français et donc évidemment cette
réforme risque d'alimenter ça donc il y
a une vraie faiblesse du côté de la
majorité présidentielle il y a eu une
division du côté de la nupes mais encore
une fois une division davantage dans la
posture que sur le en réalité et puis
une division sur le fond du côté DLR et
je défends un peu eriki il y avait quand
même un principe de cohérence
c'est-à-dire que quand même les LR n'ont
cessé de au cours de ces dernières
semaines en fait de vouloir adoucir une
loi qu'il considérait comme trop dur
trop brutal qui pourtant était beaucoup
moins que celle que proposait Valérie
Pécresse il y a moins d'un an c'est pas
là et après vous voulez aller à un peu
plus loin donc il y a quand même un
souci de cohérence en politique qui peut
se payer au prix fort on va terminer
avec le rassemblement national écouter
tiens ce qu'on dit Elisabeth borne la
première ministre elle met le RN dans le
même sac que elle est fille c'était
samedi à l'Assemblée enfin dans la nuit
devant samedi quand elle répond à la
motion de censure déposée par Marine Le
Pen malgré le chaos de ces derniers
jours et encore avec cette motion de
censure nous assistons à une forme de
clarification
la motion du censure a été déposée par
un groupe dont le silence a été
assourdissant tout au long des débats et
dont les votes
et dont les votes ne disent rien d'autre
que l'opportunisme de chaque instant
elle intervient par ailleurs après 15
jours d'agitation permanente de volonté
farouche des députés de la France
insoumise d'empêcher l'examen du texte
au fond au fond ces deux populistes se
répandent ce sont deux visages du mépris
de la démocratie
Christelle Crapelet comment vous
analysez la stratégie de Marine Le Pen
et du rassemblement national
effectivement la discrétion la
crédibilité est-ce que ça paye dans
l'opinion pour l'instant j'ai envie de
dire ça paye effectivement parce qu'ils
sont jugés moins clivant que la France
insoumise et leur image est un peu moins
mauvaise et puis je crois que ça concour
aussi un peu à la dédiabilisation et à
de l'image du parti avec le sentiment
qui sont sérieux qui se voilà qui sont
plus ils ont acquis en terme de
respectabilité mais à mon avis c'est
quand même une stratégie de court terme
parce que après ils peuvent on peut
quand même le reprocher de pas être
suffisamment offensif et puis aussi on
peut le reprocher finalement d'être dans
une opposition un peu passive mais pas
d'être assez constructif de proposer une
alternative crédible et c'est un peu
toujours l'impasse à laquelle ils sont
confrontés
c'est peut-être pas la préoccupation
première défense mais quand même sur la
réforme majeure de de ces deux trois
mois bon voilà ils ont une stratégie et
une stratégie de discrétion pas de
silence mais de quasi silence bon on l'a
vu il y a une notion de censure etc il y
a il y a une présence de Marine Le Pen
mais qui qui volontairement ne refuse
pas n'imprime pas dans l'opinion
effectivement en terme en termes de
tradimage il gagne le match face à la
France insoumise par la posture qui a
été adoptée il leur laisse le costume de
premier opposant absolument on a deux
pôles de radicalité qui autrefois
n'étaient pas au Parlement qui depuis
les dernières législatives ils sont
représentés et avec donc deux choix de
posture de choix d'opposition
radicalement différents ce qui est
effectivement frappant c'est que le
match des oppositions est plié par
Marine Le Pen face à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
par la posture de notabilisation qu'elle
a endossé sans pour autant venir sur le
fond du débat parlementaire c'est
qu'avec 89 députés 88 pardon maintenant
on choisir que l'extrême droite
travaillerait davantage ces dossiers et
en particulier sur l'avenir du modèle
social l'avenir des retraites là pour le
coup ce que le débat a traduit c'est
au-delà de la faiblesse sur le fond
l'absence totale de de vision sur le
modèle social sur le je ne suis pas sûr
encore une fois que Marine Le Pen en
sorte tant grandissement en revanche le
passage en force sur la question des
retraites sur la question du temps de
vie précisément du temps de vie choisi
du temps de répit auquel correspond en
gros dans l'imaginaire collectif le
temps de la retraite Marine Le Pen
prospère sur le sentiment de plus en
plus présent dans le pays dans l'opinion
d'être dépossédé de la maîtrise de son
temps et de la maîtrise de sa vie
précisément la retraite sert à reprendre
la maîtrise de son temps et de sa vie et
donc une réforme qui vient contrecarrer
ça risque je le crains effectivement
mécaniquement de donner du grain à
moudre à l'extrême droite allez Benjamin
Morel un mode conclusion sur la
stratégie qu'il faut pas avoir de vision
d'un observateur trop informé la plupart
des Français n'ont pas suivi du matin au
soir les débats parlementaires et donc
ce sont pas demandé quelle était la
vision profonde du R ils vont retenir de
choses en réalité d'abord le RN est
d'accord sur ce sujet que la majorité
des Français à tort ou à raison et
jugent que cette réforme est
majoritairement condamnable et le RN
là-dessus était du côté majoritaire de
l'opinion notamment de son électorat
d'électorat qu'ils vise le deuxième
élément c'est que la stratégie du RN
aujourd'hui est son vrai problème c'est
plutôt un problème de diabolisation que
de crédibilisation est-ce que demain se
pratique arrivant au pouvoir peut gérer
le pays toute la stratégie de Marine Le
Pen la cravate etc se joue sur cette
crédibilisation et là en effet il y a un
effet miroir entre la stratégie de la fi
d'un côté et la stratégie du RN vous
avez une position majoritaire assumée de
manière présentée comme étant
raisonnable donc oui pour le RN bah
c'est plutôt une très bonne séquence
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce premier débat
bientôt dans le sens